welcome back to Westeros weekly we are
live for our final episode of this
season and what a finale it was I'm ash
Crossin I'm Liana Galera and so much
happened in last night's episode we
learned Jon Snow's true name Jamie's
making good decisions for once miss
Syrian made a triumphant return ooh but
not the way we wanted to see them yeah
pretty much we have so much to discuss
for all you guys tuning in right now
first of all hello welcome to our final
show send us your comments about last
night's episode send us your theories
for next season we're gonna be
discussing all of it right now but I
think we need to kick things off with
the Nights Watch so basically so much
happened in last night's episode yes
reunions galore in that dragon pit and
yeah reunions galore Israel is right my
favorite one by the way was the hound
and Brienne discussing Aria because his
subtle smirk on his face was like the
cutest thing I've ever seen it may be so
happy I taught her what's on her well um
I actually really liked speaking of the
Hound I loved the fact that we got to
see the Hound in the mountain face off
the Hound really acknowledged that his
brothers kind of a zombie kind of zombie
kind of oddly yeah but no cooking no
game ball that was the thing that we all
thought we were getting cool and the
dragon pit but I guess we've got to save
some things for later there might be my
might we might get to it eventually yeah
exactly
but so I was really excited to see all
these characters you know the executive
producer said in the behind the scenes
of the episode we're now at like 60 Plus
hours getting to know and love all these
characters and this is the first time
that they were all in the same place at
the same time what was your favorite
part about it
um it's like my favorite and also least
favorite part was when Danny arrives on
the dragon because I also kind of
thought it was obnoxious oh she is gonna
enter like that huh and sir she's just
straight-up like I was like you're late
apologies I'm sorry
ever so much shade happening like
walking in with like the mountain and
like acting like she's such a badass and
it's like oh wait where's Danny
oh she flew in on a dragon if we went on
a dragon yeah showing off everything
she's got but they did show off the fact
that the
dead are real yes the hound tipping over
that white when should we just take a
look at this take a look at that clip
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
there see looking a little scary yeah I
think that was like maybe the first
times are one of the first times we've
actually truly seen her frightened yes
and I love that her hand of the king was
just like what is that I was worried she
wasn't gonna believe it yeah I was
worried she was just gonna be like okay
whatever so yeah but I was like huh I'm
scared I thought it was amazing I
thought I was so great I did notice that
she instinctively went like this I still
don't know if she's telling the truth of
her pregnancy but we'll get into that
further but we did get to see that
Cersei put an offer on the table and was
like okay I will help you guys if for
some reason Jon Snow only pledges fealty
to me does not get involved and just
keeps this truce going beyond the Great
War exactly and John says no no he can't
lie you can't even tell one little fib I
know I was like can you just please for
once I just lie a little bit Dani was
like that was so sweet honey and I
really appreciate it but come on come on
man come on just man up and so it's of
course down to Tyrion to talk to his
sister one of the most tense scenes I
have ever seen in this series scene was
wonderful just all the expressions in in
Lena's face like I give this woman an
Emmy give her all the Emmys all the
Emmys I want Peter Dinklage to have
another Emmy they should all have here
they should all get all the ending was
so good it was so good but in this scene
right now let's take a look right now
when he challenges her oh just just let
it play
all right you love your family and I
have destroyed it I will always be a
threat so put an end to me
if it weren't for me you'd have a mother
if it weren't for me you'd have a father
if it weren't for me you'd have two
beautiful children I love that I thought
it was such a good scene
yeah and we're starting to get in some
fan comments uh German said yes this was
the first time that I saw Cersei scared
when the white attacked her
but in that scene between Tyrion and
Cersei did you think that that was gonna
be the end of him no I didn't why I just
I felt like there's something about her
that as evil as she can be there's
something about her that still has this
like honor of not just like you're gonna
just like kill him in her room okay
she might have that honor but she did
not uphold her end of the bargain
so she eventually like tells everyone
like you know what I'm gonna be a really
nice person I'm gonna let you have my
troops to go fight the army of the
undead you're welcome I completely fell
for this by the way did you really yeah
I was like okay you're just noped out of
there like a coward
oh yeah look who's being a coward you're
on yeah she's like you know what I'm
gonna do this and hopefully you guys
will remember this because I thought at
this moment that she was like okay I'm
losing yeah yeah she's got the Dothraki
she's got the unsullied she's got
dragons I need to kind of set up this
Alliance for the future but then she was
alive she was a liar but she actually
lied to Jamie that was the worst thing
about it yeah is that she was like Oh
Jamie did you actually think that you're
on were just nope out of there no he's
going across to Essos to get me my great
army I honestly when he turned his back
on her it was one of my favorite scenes
ever I thought he was a goner
really yeah oh yeah and in this moment
don't worry about to look at right now
yeah oh yeah I thought he was gone er
let's see
gives you on that
I don't believe
oh yeah I mean when the theme started
playing and he kind of pulls us up I was
like this is how Jamie ends I was real
scared
no well and I was scared like Cersei
waiting that waiting a really good point
she says she lied to Jaime which just
gives him more ammunition to kill her in
the end I love that yeah
Oh any I also love like Theon good jobs
not being a little [ __ ] that was good
for you I'm not like standing up to
everyone and trying to go rescue his
sister I will say though I felt like the
entire Theon story did not need to be in
the finale
yeah you were saying you talked about
this on the phone last night I kind of
agree with you like I obviously wanted
to see this moment from Theon and I like
it I like that he's going after yar but
at the same time it was like it it felt
a little like slowing down the finale a
little bit it really slowed down the
finale I thought that you know it was a
great scene between him and Jon getting
to kind of have that bro moment and
realizing that like okay we can move
past our differences but that could have
been a couple episodes ago and remember
Yaga captured in episode 2 of this
season so we've had five episodes of
just straight-up or anytime I don't even
know how much time has passed and Game
of Thrones at this point but like I
can't imagine that yar has been only
gone for a little bit right and it would
have been one thing if we would have
seen throughout the season Theon's like
struggle yeah but instead he kind of
stood in the background and then all of
a sudden was like oh wait I'm gonna go
get her yeah so it was a little off but
oh so like I still liked the moment cool
you took a beating good job we're not
surprised and and the one thing that
really did about their music like kept
showing that if the guy was like
supposed to like kick him in the nuts
and it's like oh that doesn't work on
him it's like cool it's the one
advantage you have oh but I was
screaming at my TV Theon just stay down
that was like he cannot go like this
well let's move on to our favorite
ancestral couple in keeping up with the
Khaleesi even up with Khaleesi
Dany and John Jeon they get it on we've
wanted I've wanted this to happen but
then when I actually saw it play out it
is because at the same time bran is kind
of narrating the scene as bran and Sam
kind of pieced together the whole
Liyana rehgar the fact that Jon Snow is
her nephew and it's like while this is
happening it was it was just a lot to
take in at once it was a lot it was a
lot but at least people seemed to be
friendly getting on the same page yeah
this I mean this was a really cool scene
of them piecing this all together do you
want to take a look at that little
moment yeah Bran's little narration here
yeah stranger I am hers and she is mine
from this day until the end of my days
Robert's rebellion was built and alive
Rhaegar didn't kidnap my aunt or raper
[Music]
he loved her he loved all that
Confirmation Robert's rebellion was
built on a lie
ah which means that somebody is actually
the true heir to the throne and that
would be Jon Snow they say it's not Jon
Snow a guard Targaryen this kind of
annoys me let me tell you why Rhaegar
had another son named Aegon Targaryen
yeah two children named Aegon Targaryen
Aegon Targaryen is actually a very
common name for all the Targaryen I get
it like he was the first conquer he
brought the Seven Kingdoms together like
he was a very important guy but John is
technically the eighth Aegon Targaryen
he couldn't even him anything else Leona
come on Liana
she had it up I mean of whatever it it's
fine it's fine but the point is that a
hunter garyun the Jon Snow version is
heir to the Iron Throne which i think is
going to really mess things up later but
it's kind of a bummer that just because
he's a man that puts him higher in the
lineage to the Iron Throne than Danny
who's older than him
she's his aunt like she's actually I
don't know it really bothered life is
really unfair yeah sorry but John is
evilness is coming through right now but
no John John I'm gonna can I keep
calling him John yeah I guess calm John
Snow I'm not gonna be on sand no well
he's not a monster well he is heir to
the Iron Throne so that's gonna really
complicate things especially since they
just speaking of complications
Tyrion watching them knowing that they
clearly just did it he did not look
pleased what was that I was he's
standing on his wheel is he just
standing outside the room listening like
why first thought I was like does he
have a crush on Danny like who doesn't
have a crush on Danny but I don't know I
thought it was an interesting twist jane
says she was so surprised to find that
all this came together Kayla says I
think they're setting the stage for
women to come to the forefront of power
yes Kayla mm-hmm I love that um but so
we also had a lot of other things that
happen in this episode like oh I'm sorry
are we yes it's our last one of the
season one final Stark's sister update
for everybody
I love this bit that we're doing first
Aria finally comes to a close
peek moment and it was crazy sorry I
don't know how to deliver information I
really so yes we had another scene
between Sansa and Littlefinger where it
was really just kind of like drilling it
into us that oh my gosh Sansa is really
about to turn on Arya she's not digging
her sister Littlefinger is controlling
them like puppets he's playing little
games with them yep and it was so
incredibly satisfying to see this twist
we're gonna let you guys relive it right
now so let's just roll that clip you
stand accused of murder you stand
accused of treason how do you answer
these charges Lord Baelish
some somebody tweeted last night that
baelish's reaction there's the new like
the white guy blinking meme just like
but like I found myself I was so pissed
before like that twist happened because
he's just over in the corner like
smirking and I yelled it in my TV is it
stopping yeah this was like satisfying
as the is the right word because Sansa
is the smartest B no she's not yes she
is the fact that she admitted she's like
I'm a slow learner but I learned
ventually and she learns eventually but
that's really sweet it's like I like
what girls like understand what what
what their their strengths and their
weaknesses are
Aria knows that her strength is killing
and it was so satisfying mm-hmm to watch
this happen this might be a little
gruesome but I don't care let's see it
again
we're gonna roll it you brought me back
to Winterfell you told me there's no
justice in the world
not unless we make it
thank you for all your many lessons Lord
Baelish I will never forget them
[Music]
right
with his own dagger uses his final
breath to face Sun I love it
Vanessa right standing ovation for Santa
well done totally agree she is my
favorite character in this entire show
she is the best well are you okay what
have you done with my best friend ah but
we get to see you know Ariane Sansa
could not be divided they're United
together and I love you the parallel
that Sansa had to use is like you turned
my aunt and her sister against each
other we see you for what you are now
and we just love because we've hated him
this entire season the cockroach is
finally dead he's finally dead someone
finally squished him what is gonna
happen with the veil
I don't know here's my one regret of
that scene which I thought was
absolutely incredible but I would have
loved to see little Lyanna Mormont just
scowling the whole time being like hmm
yeah we're [ __ ] I don't know but I would
like to see Liana and Jorah ever meet
cuz Mormont family room oh yeah I wonder
if RA is gonna be able to wear his face
oh I'm talking about Littlefinger no not
my brains you're connected on there yeah
yeah um I think it's time to move on to
the iciest moment of the night
definitely not the ISIS moment of the
season that still was last week yeah
when we initially saw what happened to
this Ariane but now we got to see what
this dragon is actually used for and
this is so upsetting right now but so
satisfying let's take a look right now
it's okay
no it's not
[Music]
seeing this Aryan kind of decomposing a
little bit is just that was so
heartbreaking to me because I don't know
why I thought we could like get him back
somehow no yes I don't think you
couldn't come back in that but I won't
say blue flames I really did call that
you call that entire scene actually I
was like I think that he's gonna use it
to break down the wall Ashley are you
okay right now for any new fans if
there's yeah if your woman is Ashley's
heart and soul my heart my salt my man
here's the thing if it was any other
show yeah I'd be like he is a hundred
percent there's no way you survived that
but it's Game of Thrones if you don't
see a body there's a chance there's a
chance for survival
some Stannis is just gonna hop back into
our lives I just need my ginger daddy to
be alive I just need to run and Brienne
to like get it on because I really want
to see that happen because he wants to
make babies with her I hope he gets that
chance I think I think you will do you
wants to know she says I want to know
what's gonna happen next
so do we do but unfortunately we have to
wait a very long time before we start
speculating about what could happen in
season eight let's take a look at our
race to the iron throne and we're doing
right now so it was a very big week
because Jon Snow his first time has
finally been in front of anyone in this
in this race to the iron throne because
he actually is the heir to the Iron
Throne yes I am very curious to see what
the dynamic between Danny and John ends
up being because the EPs did say in the
in the inside the episode that he is
going to complicate their relationship
what I want to know is how has a more
true claim to the Iron Throne John or
dendron Gendry I can't read I can't see
John being like oh I'm the heir to the
Iron Throne I guess I'm gonna come take
it like he already kind of but he
already bent the knee to Danny I don't
think he's gonna go back on his word but
how much is Danny gonna honor what the
lineage should be I don't know that's a
good point but I I still think it's hers
I think it's yours for the takin um Oh
Cathy says if the knight King never
talks how does he tell the dragon to
shoot blue fire I was literally thinking
this last night no because I was
thinking about it too bit like I always
think about when Danny's on drogon I
think it's just like a mental thing
because whenever she's
okay it's time to leave you just leave
so I think it's just like a connection
that Dragon Riders have with their
dragons um this is a weird time but
Vinnie from Jersey Shore had this recap
of last week's episode that was so funny
cuz he was like what do they even want
they don't even talk what are they gonna
do what do they want
I don't know they just want to take
everything and just stand there what I
gonna do when they're done because they
don't eat the people what are they gonna
do I don't know but just stand there
dead there's a lot of things that we
don't know cuz let's start talking about
all the theories out there one of which
has to do with the night king and so
many people are divided a lot of people
are trying to figure out who is the true
identity of the night king so many
people are saying that it's brand other
people are saying that it is Jon Snow
thoughts yes I think okay I've always I
think the night king is just the night
game I don't think he's like a character
that we know maybe there's a story there
of like because we saw it we saw him
getting turned into the night getting
yes however my favorite theory is that
it is brand and that he has seen the war
with the army of the undead and he keeps
working himself back in time to try and
prevent this eventually from happening
and one of the theories out there was
that he initially worked himself into
the Mad King and when he was saying burn
them all he kept hearing the voices burn
them all that was brand trying to tell
them to burn all the White Walkers but
he misinterpreted and burned
everyone in King's Landing I then he
went back a little bit further and went
to go be bran the Builder which he's
named after and he built the wall as a
way to keep these people out but then of
course that didn't work out and then he
went back even further and worked into
the person that was the very first white
Walker so that's what people are saying
out there I think it's brilliant that's
what I think also subtle side note
Brandon the night King are always
wearing the same clothes it's true
they really are yeah I think I feel like
bran is is Inder indirectly or like not
on purposely responsible for a lot of
things oh yeah but I don't think I feel
like he's not the knight Kayla says I
think the knight King is a Targaryen
which could make sense if it's actually
John yeah then he'd be writing Viserion
I just can't wait for John to go on
Rhaegar or like yeah Rick we go I
thought there was a
I thought for a minute that like Rhaegar
could somehow be denied came but then I
was like the timeline doesn't really
make sense but I always kind of thought
that regard still alive
interesting yeah because Robert's
rebellion was built on a lie
Robert goes and supposedly kills him
we've never seen the body I just have
like a I'm still working on the theory
but I think Reger's my theory is Danny
is by far the looker in her family
because I'm sorry none of her brothers
have been remotely cute braids are
supposed to be like the most handsome
man in the world and the he kind of
looked like a skinny little twig series
ken could Danny actually get pregnant
yeah I think so I think so
I mean it keeps getting called out where
John's like you believe the switch yeah
why would you do that exactly and I
think she can maybe she's pregnant right
now it's that special incestuous that
word
[Laughter]
what about Cersei lying about being
pregnant I think that's true and I asked
Jamie or I asked Bigelow ask you about
that and he said you know it wouldn't be
out of the realm of possibility yeah you
never know I personally think that she
purposefully led Tyrion to believe that
like she thought she was being sneaky
and then he's like oh my gosh you're
pregnant she's like no I think she's
lying
hmm I think I totally think she's lying
because I feel like that gives her a
stronger claimed with the throne is her
by saying that oh I'm pregnant you want
to hurt a pregnant woman hmm I think
it's I think it's something good I think
it's something good how long do you
think we're gonna have to wait to see
the night king attack Winterfell oh I I
mean we don't have that much time left
so now gotta be like episode 1 of next
season there's gotta be gotta like fast
track to the end yeah
Whitney says I think Danny is gonna get
pregnant yes Mitchell says Lyanna
Targaryen becomes ruler of the Iron
Throne
I'm so sorry Mitchell she died yeah but
that would have been awesome I'm all
fans for people named Leon alien
anything like that
Linda Arya will kill the night king ooh
Arya will kill the night king can't she
go can she she can tell a lot of people
here was my thing
were you bummed that Littlefinger wasn't
actually someone who was on her list or
do you think had she known that he was
responsible for everything that happened
her family she would have added a manly
bonus kill I think she made it pretty I
think he made the list yeah she just
hasn't mentioned it all right Mitchell
try it again
Danny's baby will rule the Iron Throne
done okay I like that one and maybe the
baby will be named Lanna we have to we'd
have to like jump ahead do like a time
drum but I mean at the pace that this
series is going I wouldn't be surprised
I feel like next season's gonna pick up
like 40 years later I would really like
to know like at an exact time breakdown
of how this season worked out I don't
think we're ever gonna get that answer
and it kind of bothers me anything goes
laughing Ashley here's one enough from
you Oh make your prediction for
something you think will definitely
happen in season eight mm something that
will definitely happen in season eight I
well I'm very excited flash scared to
see Danny see Viserion in new form
it's her child yeah she doesn't know she
doesn't know uh yeah I feel like I can
already just feel that my stomach is
gonna drop just like hers somebody
somebody posted this theory I wish I
knew so I could credit you I'm sorry but
somebody said um John is gonna have to
like risk his life for Danny and a
dragon's gonna burn them but then John's
gonna merge Oh unburnt I like that oh I
really like that but let's be real John
is gonna risk his life for Danny because
John misses his life for everyone he's
just that noble of a human I cannot wait
to see John and Aria finally have their
reunion yeah I was a little bummed that
we didn't get to have that this year but
it just saves another little nugget for
next year I also want to see Sansa and
Tyrion again yeah yeah okay I feel like
he was always so kind to her I want
Tyrion to find some love I hope there's
just a significant fee on pay off
because we've spent a lot of time with
him whoo okay Brody here we go crazy
idea but what if the night King is
Rhaegar and his purpose is to go back
and kill
circe in rut in all the Roberts heritage
hmm see I can't piece together how
Rhaegar could be the night king but I
like if somebody can like make this
theory make sense I love it yes so you
guys work on that you guys work on that
here's a homework assignment assignment
because we have so much time until Game
of Thrones returns I'm really upset yeah
what are we gonna do for all this time
I'm gonna put this on my desk yeah I'm
just gonna love him I hope that we we
haven't seen ghosts all season I know
does he cost you much money what's up
with that you can pay for dragons you
can't pay it for a direwolf yeah that
hoc ghost killed a night king that's
what I want all right I like that's a
wrap up of this season of Westeros
weekly thank you all so much for tuning
in continue to leave your comments and
your theories and the in the comments
below because we're gonna be writing
them all up on each e online be sure to
keep it locked to ichi online for all
the latest TV news good our YouTube
channel and subscribe to that and like
that like and comment and of course you
can tweet us all your Westerosi theories
yeah or anything you want to talk about
yeah I'll talk about anything yeah
pretty much thanks so much for being in
my guys weekly